marvel is taking risks switching up the
tone of its storytelling well taking
risks and adding twists moon night is a
thrilling adventure and we bet filming
it was too as the actors were all over
the map today we're taking a look behind
the sets
number one feige's been called a genius
on more than one occasion kevin feige's
childhood trip to an egyptian art
exhibit inspired him to want to make
moon knight there's something about
egypt that captures the imagination and
childlike wonder he remembers feeling
thrilled to just be waiting in line to
go in and then to see all the artifacts
he was obsessed he wanted to tap into
that excitement with moon knight what do
you think has the team been successful
so far
number two imagine going for a job
interview and handing them a 200-page
package the director muhammad diab
wanted to represent authentic egypt as
best he could saying i wanted to
showcase egyptian talents as much as i
could every culture should be
represented by its people so i hired
actors an editor a costume designer an
art director and a composer who are all
egyptian i put my heart and soul into
this series i loved basing everything on
real egyptian mythology muhammad diab
and his wife sarah gohar who's also a
producer on the show did a 200 page
pitch this pitch was so thorough it
became the bible of the show tiab
admitted i wanted to push it i wanted
something that they usually wouldn't
think that they want which is i wanted
it to look and feel different than every
other mcu project which eventually is
the case they covered literally
everything in their package the
locations the tone the music the score
the action how they see egypt how they
see every location and even how to
develop the characters sarah picked out
every egyptian song herself and muhammad
credits her and all of the musicians
involved for bringing the different tone
to marvel number three even their undies
were authentic just kidding we don't
know every single texture and every
single thing was so authentic the show
was filmed under the working title good
faith it was joked that they'd brought
egypt to budapest everything was in
arabic the license plates the t-shirts
everything actor kareem l hakeem attests
it brought me back to being in cairo it
was like a flashback it was so realistic
the smells the smoke the cars the
tuk-tuks even down to the food and the
types of fruit that were on sale in our
marketplace it was really impressive
diob felt that that detail was down to
the newspaper clippings that have been
torn on the floor that's doctor level
precision number four we all need a
friend like the living statue the shots
of stephen talking to the living statue
were filmed in madok square under the
arcadia hotel in central budapest and
fun fact the living statue is credited
as crawley bertrand crawley was a
homeless man living in new york often
working as an informant for the moon
knight number five if hydra's involved
we want nothing to do with it mark wakes
up near a castle in the swiss alps the
scene contains a lot of cgi but the
fortress is inspired by else castle in
germany this isn't the first time this
castle has been used in a marvel series
either hydra's castle to crake from what
if was also modeled after the same
castle it was built in the 12th century
and has stood the test of time because
it's never been destroyed yet shouldn't
say yet number six what do moon knight
and shadow and bone have in common this
place apparently the village was filmed
in the charming town of centendra a few
miles away north of budapest it is a
beautiful little city with narrow alleys
cobblestone streets and pastel colored
buildings number 7. hey look it's
england we remember that place from
spider-man far from home the exterior
shots of england weren't actually shot
in england making parts of the city look
like london required very careful
planning because for one thing the
streets run the opposite way in budapest
the team had to add cars signs a british
red bus because we all know it isn't
london without a double-decker bus and a
ton of taxis the good news was there is
plenty of neoclassical architecture that
worked as the london backdrop and mark
spector lives roughly in the brixton
area of london the set exterior of his
flat is located in downtown budapest
near elizabeth square number eight the
design team needs high praise for this
detail steven's apartment was designed
to give the idea that he lived in an
attic to reflect the pyramids his
apartment has a ton of books historical
artifacts and maps books divide the open
space and his bed is under the loft like
he's in a tomb number 9. worlds apart
and yet similar architecture mark works
at the british museum in london home to
one of the largest collections of
ancient egypt objects outside its own
country the exterior wasn't actually
filmed in england though and instead at
another museum with a similar exterior
the museum of fine arts in budapest
heroes square and both museums are home
to a permanent ancient egyptian art
exhibit the geography in their filming
is just a bit all over the place and
odds are steven wouldn't be traveling by
bus from his flat to his work more
likely buy two number 10. from the
artifacts to the artifacts in the gift
shop the entire egyptian exhibit
interior hall was created from scratch
on a studio set a team of sculptors from
hungary and italy built all the egyptian
statues and columns the interior of the
museum took months to build as well
number eleven you know the road we're
talking about the thrilling car chase
scene on the twisty road was filmed in
osunata in southern slovenia the road is
named bear's guts and has about 20
hairpin turns if you would love to take
a skateboard down that thing turns out
you can it hosts a skateboarding race
called red bull no paws down but be
careful it's one of the most difficult
in the world
number 12 the restaurant staff were just
as excited as those guys in lady and the
[ __ ] going all out with the setup and
everything the set designers dressed up
the restaurant where steven is stood up
by his date or rather where he stood her
up it was designed to look like soho
this beautiful red curved bar is the
troger gastro bistro in budapest
number 13. this is the hottest place on
the list of places to shoot every movie
has shot here did you think we meant the
weather a little fun fact for you wadi
rum in jordan is also known as the
valley of the moon this desert location
is linked to the power of konchu many
other films have been shot in the area
two others oscar isaac was a part of too
including star wars the rise of
skywalker rogue one a star wars story
the live-action remake of aladdin
lawrence of arabia and dune isaac said
if anyone would have told me in the span
of four years i'd be going to do three
different projects in the wadi rum
desert i would have never believed them
that's fair it's a weird thing to tell
somebody it must be a nice place to be
if disney's gone back so much some of
the roads are named after the star wars
shot there too and some of the scenes in
cairo and the desert were filmed in
jordan the wadi rum nature preserve is
popular for a good reason it has some of
the world's most outstanding desert
landscapes number 14. this castle is a
replica but it wasn't made by the studio
built in 1896 in budapest to celebrate
the hungarian conquest of the
carpathians and transylvania in 1895.
this replica of corvin castle in romania
was also featured in the witcher series
and the 2019 movie with will smith
gemini man number 15. sets so authentic
you think they're real beyond sets
beyond meat should expand their market
steven would appreciate the vegan joke
the burial chamber set was built on a
gigantic 4 700 square foot soundstage at
origo studios in budapest because so
many period pieces had been filmed in
hungary the team had access to plenty of
field specific experts who specialized
in things like pottery and hieroglyphics
it took a team of sculptors brought in
from sela's native italy three months
just to create the statues of the
egyptian deities that stand in the
chamber of the gods stella designed the
set to symbolically represent steven as
well her use of water on the set and of
similarly reflective surfaces in some of
the other sets recalls the series themes
of duality and identity
marvel is changing the landscape of tv
and we can't complain about that one bit
the first couple episodes of moon knight
have given us some beautiful shots and
incredible storytelling if you could
visit any of these locations which one
would you choose let us know your
thoughts in the comments and thanks for
hanging out with us here at the things